[Music]
well you can practically hear Britney
singing jackpot yep she is heading back
to Las Vegas has the highest paid
entertainer in Sin City
Nancy oops she did it again I have so
many puns about this by the major
Britney fans are so excited but if you
want a piece of Britney where you got a
pan he has learned Britney will be back
to work in Sin City starting next year
the upcoming residency will be at Park
MGM's Park Theatre it's the same venue
as Lady gaga
a source tells ET our contract is worth
more than $500,000 per show considering
her performances are usually 90 minutes
long that's around 93 dollars a second
and yes that payday would beat out Vegas
is reigning queen Celine
[Music]
Brittany is expected to make the
official announcement in Las Vegas
tonight et has been by her side since
launching her first residency in 2013 my
show is very cool I have 22 songs in it
and it's a 90-minute set there's a lot
of dancing it's the most dancing I've
ever done in a show in my whole life
last month Britney wrapped up her piece
of me world tour she explained the
appeal of having a residency versus life
on the road it's so grueling being on
the road and like half staying at a
different bed every night like the
schedule is insane and I just thought it
would be ideal to have like one place
that I could go to and then I could just
travel back and forth to my home it just
felt really like you know the ideal
thing to do yes mom too so it's like
yeah and now she's even richer so but
did you know that's week this is perfect
timing is the 20th anniversary of baby
one more time and we're taking you back
home at all began our throwback Thursday
with Britney is coming up a little bit
later in the show
[Music]